and there's gibson his 21st start second
with the fills
seven and three with a 2.86 era
he's had a good month of august uh the
early part of it seven for 20.
and he rolls over on one of the right
side gregorius has it
6-3 on the put out they work around the
error
no runs no hits one air one man left
philly's coming up for the first time
marcus strowman if ever the mets need a
big game
from a starting pitcher it's from it's
tonight with strowman
they stealers are seven out of nine when
strowman's on the mound
this season but expecting to go again
here with that 3-2 count
herrera still the short lead there he
goes pitch is going to be swung on this
throw down hopped and boy that was not a
good slide
got him nice play nato makes the throw
and gets the out down at second base on
a
on a fall really into second
well when it's three and two when it's
three and two you're not going to try to
steal the base
and you roll the dice and segura is
supposed to put it in play does not
here's the one-two pitch with the over
shift don swung on hit high in the air
deep left center nemo back at the track
running laterally now
comes together with a left fielder smith
and dom made the catch
well as nemo started to move laterally
smith was cutting over here's dede
gregorius
strowman with the 3-2 and a swing and a
bomb
way back to right and that is headed for
the second deck
d.d gregorius with his tent and the
phillies lead
one to nothing on the solo shot from the
phil's shortstop
he got robbed of a home run yesterday
nobody's going to arrive on that one
andre the giant wouldn't even come close
oh my my goodness did he unload on that
boy
didn't he smith up two down two on
then we're down at second base and
alonso on at first
dominic smith 265 with runners in
scoring position on the year
leads the first and second hit hard that
one down the line it'll get at least
one in coming to third base
and a 1-1 ball game so he got one
and smith comes through nimmo scores
from sega base
alonso goes over to third and it's a 1-1
game
dominick has been so quick inside
this is a pretty good pitch gloria's got
the home run second inning philadelphia
had a one-nothing lead
nets came back in the third rbi base hit
by dominic smith
tying the ball game at 1-1 that's where
we are
four hits total came in and that's goes
into right that's going to be a base hit
so he got the bat around on that one hop
play it in
and conforto is on and it is a
lead off 1-1 the ground ball off the
glove of the first baseman miller in the
right field to base it
conforto takes off for third he'll make
it easily
brad miller trying to backhand a hot
shot off the bat of vr
and it kicked off the heel of his mitt
and it bounced into shallow right field
giving michael conforto plenty of time
to go to third base
so the nets have runners on the corners
nobody out three balls two strikes on
tomas nito pitch
nito takes inside ball four
nito clapping back toward the men's
dugout he had a great at bat
the mets have the bases loaded they have
conforto a third vr at second
neato at first one out here in the top
of the fourth inning in a one-one game
brandon nimmo
is the batter and nimmo bounces it out
to second base sigour to second for one
over to first in time
it's a four six double play
and he did it on the first pitch
50 times with the bases loaded in less
than two outs the mets have not scored
one ball one strike and the pitch dede
swings and drives it left center field
nimmo a long run
back toward the angled wall and he'll
reach out he makes the catch oh did he
no he dropped it
he dropped it up against the fence
dede's around second
he's on his way to third and he's there
safely
i got to believe nimmo had the ball in
his glebon and hit the wall and it
knocked the ball out of his glove i
think
he tried to corral it he had it i think
and then his
both his glove and his free hand hit the
wall and the ball just popped
now they're gonna go away and he'll take
that one towards right field where it's
hauled in
perfectly positioned was mcneil
1-1 blogging we go to the bottom of the
fifth that is a
towering fly ball to right can he carry
enough conforto is going back he jumps
and he kicks it off the base of the wall
miller's gonna go to third
it's followed by mcneal the out of town
scoreboard which is guarded by a chain
link fence it hit that chain link it
went straight down
and hit the cement at the bottom
left that's a base hit for gibson how
about that
kyle gibson an rbi single
and the phillies lead it 2-1
remarkable how about jankowski how to
get the job done huh no he did
i tell you what kyle gibson would go get
his hitters back
put the bunt that way yeah he didn't
bring the button back there
he did not hit the ball game
there's a strike three call nemo thought
about throwing the bat away but now
he'll just put it away
i don't know what he's looking for there
that was right there
he probably was looking for something
off speed
for seaman and again the 2-2
broken bat looper over the mounds segora
bumps into the fielder throws to first
in time
yes sir hector's fired up segura's fired
up 30
000 of the philly faithful are
fired up as well gene segura with
another tremendous defensive play that
ball
checked up it was spinning he grabbed it
with a bare hand
and fires a strike to miller and the
side is retired
there's the wind up in the 02 swinging
him this he's [ __ ] him out
fastball go upstairs
yep he's going to try and we'll see 3-2
delivery on the way
[Applause]
[Music]
got him that's a wide strike zone
then florida strikes out and a 1-2-3
inning as bradley gets a couple here's
harper hitless tonight
2-1 ball game the pitch from diaz out to
center field
mimos going back that one is gone
off the back wall a two-run
home run for bryce harper adding a
little insurance here in the bottom of
the eighth inning
it's a 4-1 game
[Applause]
winning that bail bryce bring it baby
into the count to the belt the payoff
pitch swung on hit high in the air
left field and deep back goes herrera
looking up
it's gone a home run jonathan vr takes
kennedy
deep and the mets get one back in the
top of the ninth inning it is now the
phillies four
and the mets two that's the second
straight day we've seen the mets only
score
one run in the first eight innings and
then start to put better at bats
together in the ninth
the 2-2 out to center field going back
out of jankowski
makes the catch in the phillies have
moved into first place in the national
league east
the mets had occupied first place for
90 consecutive days
[Music]
on this friday night in the month of
august
2021 the phillies
have brushed them aside